all right
so uh shomenucci
the strikes are uh more difficult
because the tendency is to start
arm wrestling and arm wrestling does not
work
you have to find a way
of doing the same kind of center
connection the same kind of ikey
adhesions the same coq projections
on this thing that is moving faster
than the grip okay so
when i do edv naga for example
you see that i'm affecting his center
on the move so i move him
but i'm moving him with the same uh ikey
adhesion
so i'm not just swatting him this way
everything is moving that allows me to
keep my weapons inside my outer rim
we did kotak and it's the same thing
so it's not that i'm cutting down here
but i'm still
adhering to him
but it's always affecting his center
always affecting his center
if i don't affect his balance
i'm not going to do what i think i'm
going to do
it's irrelevant whether he's attacking
me with this
archaic strike or not the task is before
me
can i gain control of
his center within this capacity
okay so as we go to uh equal
what you're going to see is a lot of
people start arm wrestling
every time you arm wrestle even in
ground fighting right
people pull their arms people punch you
[Music]
people counter you that's not what we're
doing
if you want a high percentage move even
in newaza
you have to get their balance going you
have to use your koku
and your iki so when we go to
this technique i can't just shove him
it's very similar to idi minage as i
come around here
i'm going to affect his body
home at the top of the yeah
so we come up i'm not
shoving him back i have to get
his center to come forward
give me a little energy here we go start
over
energy to come back and i'm attacking
[Music]
this
not his arm obviously not down here
not doing this and faking that
up get his center
same side center
how do i get his center it must be
allowed to pass
through and i'm doing this
oh
so here's a coup common mistakes once i
start aiming for this
is you'll go up and then you push this
back
just like hide me naked i go up and then
i move it over here
this one goes up and i turn it over here
up and then over here
so up
save you matching
[Music]
so
the nearly me must happen inside that in
space
so in here
center up around
so he's going to do show mnuchin i just
want you to see the
energy so i'm going to take this up
right let his center go through
and then his arm is going to come around
this way
you see because this is where his
balance is you see
pushing him back here you're going to
have to be stronger than him
this is this is where he wants to fall
so he comes in
it goes up up and then
this way let it go forward
around you
so he goes up around me here
this is where he wants to fall
and i'm only interested right now in the
first part oh
this part
this is different to me
it's about his center center
now you can of course finish the
technique
but let's just get reps on the first
part
yeah he falls he falls on his own when
when you're down it's very easy
you start going like oh bring it around
and now your arm wrestling again
okay
so we go come back up
push stand up
push on the arm it's ground path
ground pod right and i'm going to turn
it
around me this is the adhesion part so i
don't need to grab it that's the
adhesion part
so when we go standing this stuff like
you're waiting
people will find you it's got to be a
matter of pin
[Music]
is
oh
okay so what is allowing me to stick on
him is his forward progress
okay if i stop that forward progress and
start
pushing it that's why you have to use
his arm to manipulate him
you're using his body
[Music]
you're using his momentum so don't stop
it keep letting it come out from laundry
whoa
does it
oh one more thing don't move your hands
over your other side
here straight up
no i was never bringing it that way
anyways
so straight up
don't telegraph